business analyst
interview questions my name is richard
kirschner with the simply learn team
get certified get ahead we'll go over
some beginner
intermediate and advanced level
questions to expect in interviews
when you're looking at business
analytics
let's start with the differentiation
between a risk
and an issue and this should be a very
fundamental question
uh dealing with business because in
business they want to make money
and we really want to understand where
the split is on a lot of these things
always ask yourself where is the bottom
dollar on this
and what does this mean risk is your
potential
and an issue is something that's
actually happening
so risk is a potential problem that can
be predicted risk may or may not happen
in the future
a proactive response plan is formulated
and kept ready to mitigate
risks so these are things you plan for
and the issue refers to a risk that is
occurring or about to happen
there is no response plan in place to
solve an issue you can only respond
reactively to an issue
what are the various tools a business
analyst works on
this is very company
specific and so when you start looking
for work you start going in for
interviews
you should start really asking yourself
what are these companies looking for
that i'm
interested in clearly if you work with
ibm you want to
have your tools that are central to ibm
and the ibm
setup same thing with google
with you know just across the whole
field
some of the more basic ones obviously an
excel spreadsheet which isn't on this
list
but your python your sql you should
really know your sql
it's going to come up in no matter what
format you're in
your tableau your xjour your balsamic
all these are different platforms
there's a lot more out there
but you should be aware on which
platforms your proficiencies are on
and those also that you might not be
proficient on but you at least know what
they do and what their performance is so
you can answer
questions and a lot of companies will
pay for you to be certified if their
platform isn't on your list
what are the various stages of a
business project
and we look at project initiation
project planning project execution
project control and monitoring project
closure
and it's really important to understand
one of these in a little bit more detail
than just knowing the list
what is feasibility study a feasibility
study is a method of gauging the success
rate of proposed
business solution it enables business
analysts to discover
new business opportunities
and uh really a lot of businesses when
they're looking at a for a business
analyst
this is really what they want to know
what's the feasibility that is a very
central question that comes up
in most business plans what's the
feasibility of doing something and
getting it done
what is business model analysis business
model analysis
is a technique that helps you analyze if
a business is financially economically
and socially
viable or not i know a number of
contractors that this is their sole
career is to go in and analyze
ski resorts in colorado to find out
whether it's going to make it this year
or not and what they need to do to fix
that
so it's a very high-end job niche
where you really need to know your stuff
and understand what it means
what do you understand by requirement
differentiate between requirements
and needs we look at requirements
requirement is a targeted solution that
is required to achieve the set
business objectives business
requirements are data used for business
processes
needs needs are the high level
representation of the terms and the
result
business needs include identifying and
comprehending the businesses goals
and articulating its strategic direction
and you can think of needs are what do
we need to succeed
requirements are well these are the
things we need to put into place this is
what's
required to achieve a business objective
suppose you have been given a list of
zip
pin codes from different countries
using those codes find the city and the
state names using excel
and so if you're given a list of zip
codes pin codes of various cities from
the us and india
here's how you can find the city and the
country names select all the codes
go to the data tab under data types
select geography
click on the insert data option choosing
city from the field list
click on the insert data option and
select state from the field list
really you do need to know your way
around excel no matter
what other packages you're working with
excel is such a base package in business
analysis
so much people are giving that back and
forth still it's still kind of a
baseline
below our sales data that has
information on
different items sold across various
regions and countries
what was the total revenue generated for
all the items in
india you can use the sum
if function to find the total revenue
generated from india
you can see here equals sum f and then
of course b2 to b100 india
l2 to l1001 and that will give you
the sum you can also use a filter option
to filter the data only for
india and use subtotal by pressing alt
plus
equals nice short hotkey to remember
there
create a highlight table to visualize
the revenue generated from
offline and online cells for different
items across the region using tableau
now not all companies use tableau but it
is becoming a very highly used tool
because it's so easy to use
you drag the region onto columns drag
the cells channel and item type fields
onto rows
select the total revenue column and drag
it on to
color and label cards select square as
the mark type drag the total revenue
field onto columns
drag the total profit column onto rows
place item type column one to colors
under the size card place a total profit
drag the region column
into the filters card and select asia
so one of the things about tableau is it
looks real complicated but it's all drag
and drop
and so you should know your way around
about doing some very simple drag and
drops
for doing your query and summation and
below is the resulted plot
so let's look at some more questions but
let's jump to a little more intermediate
level
differentiate between software
development life cycle and project life
cycle
so look a little bit more hierarchical
towards the top of the list
software development lifecycle helps
with the development of software
products it consists of a single
software across multiple phases
here phases include requirement
gathering coding operations maintenance
and
documentation where the project life
cycle
this enables you to develop a new
product in the business project
lifecycle
consists of multiple software in one
customer scenario
phases here are idea generation
screening development
testing and analysis how do you perform
risk management in your project so again
we're dealing with intermediate not just
how to pull
tables across we start analyzing things
and the risk management is a technique
wherein risks are identified
avoided reduced assessed and mitigated
having the appropriate risk management
plan decreases
losses and optimizes decision making to
enhance the organization's performance
how does risk mitigation differ from
risk avoidance
risk mitigation risk mitigation is a
plan to be executed when a risk
occurs when a risk occurs there might be
a business impact and the cost
incurred is high risk avoidance whereas
risk avoidance is carried out to avoid
the risk from occurring
meanwhile the business impact here is
zero and the cost is fully eliminated
and you can think about a brick and
mortar store
and they have shoplifting you want to
mitigate as
you want to avoid as much shoplifting as
you can
but you can only frisk people at the
door and have security so much before
you start losing customers
and so when you mitigate it you're going
to have to pay for your lost merchandise
where you avoid it you have your
security cameras and people watching to
stop
people from stealing things
risk in this case can mean loss of money
spent
badly spent on equipment certifications
there's all kinds of areas
where you want to mitigate and avoid
risk what are project deliverables
project deliverables represent a
collection of measurable services and
goods that are to be delivered to the
end user
in the project completion stage this is
so important we start talking about any
of our uh
when you sign a contract any of our
online contracts cloud computing all of
that
make sure you're very clear what the
deliverables are who owns it
who is the responsibility of the service
and the security around it
those are all very important questions
to know
differentiate between the agile and
waterfall model
two of our biggest or most basic models
used today
the agile model which is slowly taking
over especially in software
the agile model is adaptable to
requirement changes and has an
incremental approach
in the agile mile model testing can be
performed in every phase
with the waterfall model the waterfall
model is referred as a structured
software development methodology changes
and requirements are difficult to
implement meanwhile in the waterfall
model testing is performed only in the
final phase
and you can look at this as a lot of the
software today has to be
ready to change quickly when the
waterfall
uh setup you're not looking for fast
changes you're looking for a very solid
it's going to work no matter what kind
of view this is something that we can
build it doesn't have to make major
changes but it better work correctly
describe the different analytical
techniques like
moscow and swat moscow analysis
it is a prioritization technique that
highlights a requirement's significance
question like is it a must-have or it
should have
could the demand be made better would a
specific idea be useful in the future
are asked here in the swot analysis it
discovers the strengths and weaknesses
of a firm and evaluates them
as opportunities and threats
swot analysis consists of strengths
weaknesses opportunities and
threats and you can kind of think of it
as like the swat
team coming in uh to you know be worried
about threats here so we're talking
about policing
or in moscow really what is um what can
we get out of this
you know is this do we have to have it
to succeed is it gonna be useful in the
future
so you're looking more for a general
value attached to it
list various components of strategy
analysis
for developing a strategic plan for an
organization
the vital components are vision
objectives
mission strategies action plan
what is benchmarking benchmarking is a
process
of evaluating an organization's measures
like the quality of policies programs
etc
against the standard criteria it's so
important to have that baseline
of what are you measuring against the
baseline might not even be a very good
one
but you can't measure something unless
you have something to measure it against
it helps with the measuring the
performance of the company you can
recognize the areas of improvement in a
company and
analyze how other companies achieve
other objectives
what is the best approach to work with
difficult stakeholders
a business analyst interacts with many
professionals during his work
few of the best approaches to take into
consideration while working with
difficult stakeholders are
before i even jump into this i have a
friend who is working with
some very high-end individuals who took
their private plane
and he was supposed to meet him at the
in location when he arrived
they had been in a fist fight while on
their private plane the stakeholders had
so much difficulty with some particular
aspect going on
so difficulties are going to arise
hopefully not at that level but things
happen
and of course you want to just assume
work with anybody but you want to listen
patiently to the stakeholders point of
view
respond to them politely and
diplomatically have a one-on-one
discussion to make things more
precise comprehend their worries and be
transparent
make sure to continuously engage such
difficult stakeholders
and i'm going to highlight the last one
because if you're working with somebody
who's difficult
and you just try to ignore them
one of the things is that whatever
problems are arising they're just going
to explode
so that is so important not to ignore
the ignore
somebody who's being difficult but the
rest of it
is stay focused stay focused on what
you're trying to accomplish
be goal driven this is a great time to
be goal driven
not driven by emotion or the problems
that arise or how the person
communicates
name the different types of agile
methodologies
scrum go get scrum certified important
thing to look into if you haven't
learn software development and extreme
programming xp
feature driven development fdd
crystal kanban dynamic systems
development method dsdm
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description
to know more there is an agile
just a ton of different methodologies so
knowing at least a few of them inside
and out and having a kind of a general
idea that the other ones are out there
is important to at least know what we're
talking about when someone comes up and
talks about agile
describe the gap analysis gap analysis
refers to the analysis of
differences between the existing systems
functionalities and the targeted system
the gap indicates the amount of work
required to get the intended result
gap analysis is a comparison between the
current and proposed functionalities and
you can see here we put together
an action plan to go from the current
state to the desired state
how do you import text file data into ms
excel
and remember excel is one of those
things that has been around forever and
even though it's like the bottom barrel
of a lot of
uh analysis that we do most of our data
starts in an excel spreadsheet
or comma separated variable file that
you then end up with an excel
spreadsheet given below is the employee
text file it has information about name
agent company
and here's how you can import this data
into excel go to the data tab
click on get data drop down under
from file select text csv select where
the text file is located in your system
and click on import
click on load data imported into excel
you've been given cells data that has
information on the cell
of different items across the world
below is the data
create a pivot table to analyze the
profit of all the items in each region
now remember our pivot table is a table
of statistics that summarizes the data
of a more extensive table so it takes a
full data sheet and we're just going to
bring
we're going to focus zoom in on
something that's what the pro the pivot
table means
if we want to go ahead and do this we do
is go ahead and select a cell in the
table
go to insert and click on pivot table
in the create pivot table box choose
existing worksheet to place your pivot
table
drag region and item type onto rows drag
total profit onto values
sort the sum of the total profit column
using the cells table find the
percentage contribution
of cosmetics to the total revenue and
total profit
create a pivot table by dragging item
type onto rows
select the revenue and profit column
under values
right click on the revenue value under
show value as select
percentage of grand total right click on
a profit value under show value as
choose percentage of grand total and you
can see here when we do that we end up
with cosmetics made a 14.03
contributions to the total revenue and
an 18.9
percent contribution to the total profit
how do you create a dual axes chart in
tableau
drag the order data onto columns and
convert it into continuous year
drag total revenue onto rows and total
profit to the right corner
of the view until you see the light
green rectangle
synchronize the right axis by right
clicking on the profit axis
under the marks card change sum total
revenue to bar
and sum total profit to line and adjust
the size and color
they're lots of fun to play with as you
start getting into these
using the sales data create a view to
show the total units sold
and the profit generated from each item
which item
sold the police and has least profit so
we'll go ahead and load an excel
file data in tableau desktop drag units
sold onto columns and item type
column onto rows place the total profit
column under color and choose the
desired color palette
sort the unit's sold axes in descending
order
you can see here it produces a very
quick bug figure shows a fruit sold
and the least and had the least amount
of profit
create a map to show the units sold and
the profit generated
from different middle east and north
africa items
drag country onto the detail card place
a total profit column under size
drag unit sold under color in the
filters card drag the region column and
select
middle east and north africa
bahrain had the maximum number of units
sold at the same time
iran made the full amount of profit
create a visualization to analyze a
total revenue and the units sold
for clothes meat and baby food across
different regions in 2006 and 2017.
drag the units sold filled on the
columns drag the region and item type
fields on to rows
under the cooler card place a total
revenue column drag
item type onto filters and choose close
meet and baby food
drag the order date column onto filters
and select 2016 in 2017.
meat had the highest units sold and made
the maximum profit
now with any of these tableau it's good
if you have your own hands on for this
so that's an important thing to note we
kind of zoomed in on tableau
again there's a lot of other companies
out there using a lot of other packages
so if you're not familiar with tableau
but you're able to do this in another
package
that's a good thing so at least you know
what we're talking about and you've had
that hands-on
let's go ahead and jump to some advanced
level questions
what is requirement prioritization name
the different techniques used for it
requirements prioritization focuses on
allocating requirements depending on the
business
urgencies this is essential for the
project to run well
requirement prioritization enables
various teams to understand what is
important
and work in sync with the business needs
there are several techniques used for
requirement prioritization
we had moscow technique we mentioned
that earlier the requirements are
grouped based on
must mandatory should high priority
could not necessary but preferred and
would suggested for the future
ranking method here you give each
requirement a distinct numerical value
based on its importance
of course this is at 100
oh well here's kind of similar to
ranking is a 100
method multiple stakeholders get a no
notional 100
to distribute among the requirements so
the 100
method is pretty similar to what the
ranking method is
top 10 requirements and this approach
from a large set the stakeholders simply
pick
their top 10 requirements this is
very popular there's a lot of help books
out there about getting
things done they say write everything
that you want to accomplish
put them on three by five cards and
narrow it down to five
do those five because once you've
conquered those five then you can move
on to the next ones
name the critical agile metrics that
should be considered by a business
analyst
sprint burn down so the sprint burn down
is the
chart we use when you're tracking
usually it's in scrum is where that
usually comes from the scrum
setup but it's a chart of the work to be
completed and what's still going on
you have your work category allocation
the velocity
the cumulative flow diagram defect
removal awareness
time coverage defect resolution time
explain bpmn
bpmn business process model and notation
gateway controls the flow of interaction
and sequence of processes
it is a flowchart technique which models
the end-to-end business process step
the four essential elements of bpmn are
flow objects events activities gateways
connecting objects
sequence messages associations swim
lanes
pool or lane artifacts data object
group annotation list the elicitation
techniques the elicitation process is
about gathering requirements from users
and stakeholders
listing below are a few techniques that
are used to collaborate with users or
clients
interviews i don't know how many times
i've been on the phone calling
competition potential clients to ask
questions
so one of the elicitation techniques is
to ask questions if you're going to call
clients to ask questions a lot of times
also turn into additional sales
document analysis focus group
prototyping brainstorming my favorite
brainstorming
all these are important i just kind of
highlight a few of them that i tend to
get stuck in
observations and workshops again
workshops are a great sales technique
also so as you're doing your business
analysis
and you're bringing people into a
workshop and do observations in the
workshop and working specifically with
these people
they turn into potential business growth
i tell you what if you're a shareholder
and someone's doing a business analysis
and they turn around
and generate a 30 000 sell for your
company
um they're in you know you've already
earned your you've already earned your
pay
and you're doing what you like which is
business analysis
interface analysis questionnaire and
survey
questionnaire surveys my least favorite
but they are the most popular because
they're the easiest to
pump out list of documents needed by a
business analyst initiation document
project vision document use cases
system requirements specifications
document
business requirement document
requirements
traceability matrix functional
requirement document
use case specifications document gap
analyst document describe how you would
approach a project
here's a basic project approach outline
which you can use with respect to
different situations
identifying the project goal formulating
the work plan
defining the requirements collaborating
with other teams
tracking the project documenting the
progress
and really when you start
designing your project approach
encompassing all the things listed in
here so important with the shareholders
if you i mean it's great if you can
identify your project goal and that's
probably the most important thing
because if you don't have a goal
you might as well walk away
but if you don't have the rest well how
are you formulating the work plan
defining the requirements collaborating
with other teams
that is such a big step because we're
going from
everything being on paper and trying to
figure out what you're going to do to
actually doing it
and then tracking and finally
documenting very important for the
shareholders and what goes back to the
top
differentiate an alternate flow and
exception flow in a use case diagram
from a basic flow
basic flow represents the operation of
activities as required by the company
in a use case alternate flow as the name
suggests
is an alternate solution used in a
system failure case
different steps are used to complete the
goals of a use cases
exception flow refers to the various
steps executed in case of errors
this does not lead to achieving the
required goal of a use case
critical aspects of creating analytical
reporting
analytical reporting is a type of
business reporting which provides data
analysis
information and recommendations it
enables people to use data to make
decisions
to create analytical reporting the
following points should be kept in mind
comprehend business analysis display
your analysis skills
think critically and i'm going to throw
in here
the term from big data map and reduce
really when we're doing a business
analysis
you don't want to give them a massive
amount of information you want to reduce
it down to something that they can see
in a single graph a very simple set of
notes
and you need to think critically you
need to really make it what is it that
the shareholders
want that's going to make them
understand why this is important to the
business
and what does the business get out of it
what is
kanban ken ben agile teams in visually
managing work through processes
it works as a scheduling system in agile
just in time
production the kanban methodology is all
about real-time communication of
capacity and full transparency of
work the kanban board describes a
current development status
and of course when you're working with
kanban you've got to be very careful
about
[Music]
inspiring versus coaching versus
micromanaging
it really can end up in a micro
management setup where you want to you
want to watch out for that but you also
need to track everything
a basic kanban board has three step
workflow
as the to do in progress and done
however depending on a team size
structure and objectives the workflow
can be mapped to meet any particular
team's unique process
state the key differences between brd
and srs
brd business requirements documents is a
high-level functional specification of
software
brd is a formal document to describe the
requirement provided by
the client business analysts create this
post through interaction with the
clients
srs system requirement specification is
a high level functional and technical
specification of software
srs describes the software's functions
and non-functional requirements that are
needed to be developed
whereas srs is created by the systems
architects
what is pareto analysis the pareto
analysis helps
in crucial decision making it helps in
prioritizing decisions
identifying the most relevant and the
least decision
concerning the overall goal it is also
known as the 80 20 rule
as per this rule 82 percent of the
project's benefit arises from 20 percent
of the work vice versa eighty percent of
the case problem can be due to twenty
percent of the causes
differentiate between the v model and
the fish model
we talk about the v model it is an sdlc
model
where the execution of processes happens
sequentially in a v
shape at every stage the same person
reviews but other testers will do
software testing in the last step
v model consumes less time and costs
the fish model is similar to the v model
but with more multiple verification
teams
every stage is tested by another team
for completeness and correctness
the fish model is compared to the very
costly and time consuming
which makes sense because if you have
multiple tests on each stage
for multiple teams they have to all be
spun up on it and so you're literally
more than doubling the work because you
also have to track all that
given the sales data create a chart to
show each region's country that made
the highest revenue create a pivot table
by dragging the region and country
onto rows place the total revenue column
under values
right click on the country value select
the filter options and choose top
ten choose top one as shown above and
click on ok
and you can see here is the pivot table
that you will get
using the sales data find all the
countries where the total units of
fruits sold
offline were less than three thousand
you need to use
an advanced filter option in microsoft
excel to solve this problem
below is a critical based on the
question we have go to the data tab
select advanced filter option choose
copy to another location
give your criteria range and the copy to
location click on ok
here's the final result as we can see
below let's create a pivot table to find
which countries from each region made
the lowest
amount profit create a pivot table by
dragging the region
and the country into rows place the
profit column under values
right click on any country value select
the filter option and choose top 10
choose bottom one and click on ok
let's create a filled map to analyze the
total revenue and profit generated from
beverages in north america using tableau
drag country under detail card place a
total revenue column under the text
drag total profit under kalur in the
filters card drag the region column and
select north america
in the filters card drag the item type
column and select
beverages and you can see from the below
map you can see that greenland and the
maximum revenue and profit generated
from beverages in
north america who knew
using tableau how will you display the
top five and bottom five items based on
profit
drag the item type filled under rows and
total profit onto columns
right click on the item type column to
create a set give a name to the set and
select the top tab to choose the top
five items by sum
total profit
create a set for the bottom five items
by some total profit
select both the sets right click to
create a combined set
give a name to the set and choose all
members in both sets
drag the new set on the filters and the
total profit onto
calor the above graph depicts the
cosmetics made
the highest profit while fruits made the
lowest and
really when we're talking about tools
like tableau
or if you're targeting companies working
in r
or you're targeting companies working in
python
you should be able to quickly do these
kind of displays in
any of those packages that you're
focused on
tableau is one of the biggest ones out
there right now because it is
a paid for service but it's also very
robust and easy to use and uses less
programming on the back end
so just a quick side note on there
really just leads up
if you if this does not look right to
you you're not able to get through some
of these things
make sure you are if that's what you're
targeting in a company for an interview
so thank you for joining us today simply
learn
get certified get ahead for more
information
please visit www.simplylearn.com
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here